[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça décoller rien
ensemble vous allez paraît alors
allons-nous nous
il est
[Musique]
verra de la même alors au 5000 dans la
commune du Tampon plus précisément ici
la forêt des Hauts de Montvert et ben
nous ça nous a fait c'est nous ça a fait
un aller-retour pour une découverte
comment la forêt elle est allez
allons-nous
par mon collègue auparavant d'accord que
ici Lille avait enlevé 400 kg de déchets
métallique le toute la parcelle l'été
envahi par eux des encombrants
donc nous l'a appris le temps de
défricher pendant un bon moment et après
nous la replanté jusqu'à 1500 plans
d'espèces endémiques
les fleurs jaunes on a des bois de neuf
m'a aussi des chats vieillesse ce qui
trouve sur ce secteur là donc ne vérifie
que les espèces envahissantes ils prend
payer envahit pas trop quoi donc quels
ont des espèces envahissantes vanille
justement empêche de paiement endémique
poussée alors ici
on a le micro cosmien là le style orange
que nous voile dans le coin là-bas
l'agent que d'Europe d'ailleurs il y en
a un paquet de repousses qui ressent
donc si nous fait pas une limite une
lutte permanente contre ça ben
rapidement la place et du coup là quel
autre travail l'équipe il fait sur le
site sur le site là il faut entretenir
des DALO entretenir on en a la tonte à
faire c'est pareil s'il fait pas tout ça
ben la piste elle est rapidement veille
aussi les plus accessible
comment il est ça va ça va bien
poser un petit peu
parce que
la forêt d'un forêt de Montvert d'accord
surtout en tant que personne âgée quand
vous prend quand personne âgée diabète
cholestérol et tension mais la marche
les bons pour la santé au Sénégal
tous les jours surtout dans la forêt
comme ça il fait du bien et qui saladier
vient aujourd'hui dans la forêt des
Hauts de Montvert parce que tout le
temps comme il traverse dessus pour
aller pour aller demain me voir le
chemin midi un de ses jouets il faut mis
les visites ça parce que là par la même
occasion avec ma fille et ben elle est
jolie il invite voir le paysage et
justement est-ce que c'est les marches
c'est facile tu demandes facile
familiale me direz bien tout le monde
peut venir c'est votre cas les gars
découvre la forêt de continuation
[Musique]
retrouve mon moment rien que la même mot
qui a des dents derrière Elena la
montagne ni un soleil atroce fait pipi
comme si la nature déconnait à la
paradis pour nous rester
[Musique]
mais il est bien dans la commune du
Tampon alors maintenant le saint-pierre
là
en fait la forêt effectivement l'entrée
chez la commune du Tampon mais la forêt
elle-même l'échelle la commune de
Saint-Pierre et là si on continue plus
loin on va sors de la forêt pour aller
chez la forêt c'est la Forêt de la Mort
qui est sur la commune de petite île et
comment la passer mal à la ville avait
bon paiement est-ce que c'est une
particularité du site on a beaucoup
d'espèces différents effectivement au
lieu d'un forêt de Mao ici une forêt
humide de montagne donc on va voir que
Lena des espèces un peu emblématiques
comme le tamaradeo comme le temps rouge
des choses comme ça qu'on retrouvait
assez couramment la forêt fait à peu
près 200 Hector il a de quoi jouer
d'accord et ici nous replante
régulièrement bah des espèces
endémiques indigènes pour permettre à
cette forêt là de retrouver son état
initial tu vois ok
département que les très important aussi
parce qu'il permet à nous d'avoir
vraiment une ressource c'est ses
plantations là que il permet à nous
aujourd'hui ben c'est ses
investissements là qui permet
aujourd'hui d'avoir vraiment une action
beaucoup plus forte qu'avant si tu veux
en tout cas les gagnants on se connaît
un super travail mais si ça continue
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment
allez-vous
[Musique]
exactement donc il passe là ils sont là
depuis Saint-Pierre ils sont là ils
arrivent là et après il refuse il suit
l'itinéraire que les en face de nous et
montre pas là il monte pas d'accord
1300 mètres de dénivelé que les
couronnes dans les pattes depuis
Saint-Pierre
Ravine Blanche pour arriver justement
beaucoup plus haut pour une femme de la
paix ce qui va jouer ici c'est le froid
c'est les coureurs arrivent la nuit
d'accord donc là c'est pour mieux passer
en général tout le monde y arrive la
nuit parce qu'il y a un gros poste de
ravitaillement les utilisateurs des
espaces des espaces naturels
des sports nature la grosse
problématique ici c'est c'est c'est de
de limiter l'impact sur les déchets
parce que la nature elle est pas là pour
réceptionner toutes nos toutes nos
déchets en tout cas c'est un beau
message voilà merci à vous
dans la forêt des Hauts de mon verre tu
es vraiment derrière et on a vu plante
pour nous
allons pour le temps visite et pour ça
rendez-vous dans la prochaine épisode de
l'émission de nous on sera du côté de la
nouvelle
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]